to me the real winners are the ones who
step out of the game entirely who don't
even play the game Who rise above it and
those are the people who have such
internal mental and self-control and
self-awareness that they need nothing
from anybody else so there are a couple
of these characters that I know in my
life some older gentlemen that I like to
kind of learn from and we mentioned our
polish friend earlier I would consider
him successful because he doesn't need
anything from anybody he is at peace he
is at health and whether he makes more
money or less money or with the next
person over from him does better or
worse than him has no effect on his
mental state and bearing and
historically I would say that the
legendary Buddha or
krishnamurti who stuff that I like
reading they are successful quote
unquote in the sense they step out of
the game entirely winning or losing does
not matter to them there's some line
that I read somewhere that all of man's
troubles arise because he cannot sit in
a room quietly by himself for half an
hour right